if you
ask the question who is the greatest
grappler
that i've ever seen i would say
i've never seen anyone better than
gordon ryan
now people are going to jump when i give
these two names they're going to say
well
daniel you're close friends with hodger
and you're close friends with
gordon so you're biased um i i
can't answer them to that it's true i'm
good friends with both of them
um i'm also a notoriously cold and
unemotional person and i'm saying this
based upon
things that i've observed if i honestly
believed that
i'd seen other people who were better i
would have said it um
that's i will that convince the people
who
criticize me of bias probably not but
those are the two names that i will
mention
i think it's uncontroversial statement
to say that gordon ryan
is one of the the greatest grappler ever
yeah gordon's obviously a very
polarizing figure and
people tend to react to gordon on an
emotional level rather than
a statistical level and that colors a
lot of people's minds
but i also have the benefit that i've
seen both of these guys extensively in
the gym
and that all adds a whole new
perspective like if you think those guys
are dominant
on the stage wait till you see them in
the gym it's even a different level of
domination
uh above and beyond what they did in
competition
have they trained against each other no
they never trained together they've been
in the same gym i think only on one
occasion
when hodgy was stopped by new york he
came back and came by to say hello and
gordon was here at the time they they
shake hands they know each other and
they're both wonderful people in their
own way
what makes gordon ryan the greatest
grappler
of all time so good with gordon he's
also very strong on fundamentals a lot
of my students are
but he's also obviously a member of a
new generation of
nogi grapplers that also bring in
technologies that
weren't really emphasized in previous
generations specifically
the prolific use of lower body attacks
especially from bottom position
this means that he can play a game
between upper body and lower body
which was not really a part of hodge's
game
nonetheless you will also see
significant similarities he's got a very
strong and crushing
passing game to mount and very strong
and crushing
passing game to the back
you will see that the major differences
between the two
are from bottom position hodges bottom
game is essentially based around his
close guard
gordon ryan's game is based around his
butterfly guard
so one is based on outside control and
one is based on inside control
one focus almost entirely on the
classical notion of
getting past the legs to the upper body
and the other one works between the two
as alternatives and sees them as
competing alternatives
where the stronger you become at one the
more your opponent has to overreact and
become vulnerable to the second
so they have strong similarities in top
position but are very different in
bottom
he has uh from an outsider's perspective
a calm to him in the uh
in the heat of battle that's like
uh that's inspiring and confusing is
there
something you could speak to the
psychological aspect of gordon ryan
yes people will talk
all day about sports psychology and
um they will often have heated arguments
as to what's the right side
psychological state to be and when you
go out to compete
i've never seen any one school of
thought which
gave noticeably better sports
performance than another
i've never seen any psychological
mindset
prove to be reliably more efficient
or effective than another i've seen
fighters that were scared
out of their minds when they went out
every time to fight
and yet they were very successful i've
seen fighters go out
who were relaxed and calm and they too
can be successful
i've seen both mindsets win i've seen
both mindsets lose
i've seen every extreme between them
what i generally recommend with regards
your mind and preparation going in find
what works for you
everyone's different don't try to give a
one size fits all
and something as vague and confusing as
the human mind
having said that my preference
i don't force it on people because
everyone's different but my preference
is to try and advocate for a mindset of
unexceptionalism most people see
competition as something exceptional
it's not your everyday grappling session
you know you train
300 times for every time you compete and
so they see competition is something
exceptional different scarier more
nerve-wracking there's a crowd watching
these cameras
my reputation is on the line i'm going
to be observed and judged
and so they see it as this exceptional
event my general preference
is to see it as an unexceptional event
to see everything else
the noise the cameras the crowd
as illusions the only reality is a stage
an opponent on the other side of it and
a referee adjudicating you
and to make it as unexceptional as
possible
gordon does an extraordinarily good job
of of doing that
gordon looks more tense in most of his
training sessions than he does in his
competitions
because he knows his training partners
are typically better than the people
he's actually going out to compete
against
um and you see it in its demeanor
it's one of just complete calm it also
goes back to
what we talked about earlier about the
power of escapes
gordon ryan is almost impossible to
control for
extended periods of time in most of the
inferior positions in the sport
and most of the submissions so he goes
out
in the full knowledge that the worst
case scenario
isn't that bad for him and so nothing
could really go
that badly wrong he can always recover
from any given mistake and go on to
victory
when you believe those things you can
have a calm demeanor
you